anh
alo alo Xin chào bạn
em đi chơi nhỉ
anh alo lên rồi đúng không
Anh ở tốt nhiều với ông tôi cảm Thế cuối
tuần vừa rồi trả lãi
ờ ờ
à à
Xin chào bạn hôm nay thì ở
từ hôm nay tôi định mà kiểu sẽ dạy là
L'Oreal nó Khánh Anh ấy khá nhanh Mọi
việc
hôm nay làm xe Road
nick lại bé này đủ to Trưa
mai làm xe đồ rê kiểu
liên quan tặng 2 3 gạch ở trong nhà sẽ
D1 bảo hôm trước được ra cho Làm sao
không bị không biết hôm nay có làm cái
bạn được không Nếu mà về các bạn thì
mình nghĩ là làm xong một bản thì rất là
nhanh
Ê bà lên nhảy sang bạn có ai thì kiểu
copy paste ngọn rất là nhanh thôi Ờ ờ
anh nói chung và bù hôm nay mình nghĩ là
sẽ dài hơn một chút
gọi là hơi bị quá tải kiến thức mới ý
nếu mà về cơ bản thì các bạn cũng sẽ
thấy toàn bộ mọi thứ rất là ngắn ngắn
dùng tin nhắn
thì mình sẽ cho các bạn biết được làm
toàn bộ tính năngxem thêm sửa xóa trong
vài dòng như thế nào là rất là ngắn nên
là nó chỉ nó không khó về cơ bản các bạn
cũng hiểu qua cái sẽ lô đề nó gì rồi
chẳng qua là nó mới thôi nó không thấy
khó
ừ ừ
từ ngày tôi cấu tạo cái code with me cho
mấy ông nha
ạ Và bây giờ sợ bạn chưa bắt đầu học đâu
à
bộ nhông Bảo trước thì vào thôi
em
tranh thủ 4 phút mình sẽ tâm sự một tí Ờ
ưu
tiên thì mình là mình có suy nghĩ về cái
việc may mắn ờ
có cái may mắn không biết là mấy hôm Có
nghĩ mình may mắn không
nhưng mà cái may mắn đồ với tôi thì nó
sẽ và cậu
khi tôi cảm thấy tôi may mắn trí nhớ
người khi được ngồi đây khi mà cậu đã
trải qua rất nhiều chuyện
AE theo kiểu là nhà
ở một vài năm trước thì cho sản Nam Định
sẽ cảm ơn nghĩ mình như bây giờ đấy mình
mình cảm thấy mình cứ có tin tưởng mà cứ
phấn đấu làm cái gì đó sau đó thì mình
sống nhờ hi vọng thôi sống nhờ sự tự tin
và hi vọng cùng được Cũng gọi được buồn
như bây giờ chưa phải là kiểu thế ra
trong tay tôi vẫn chưa có cái gì cả
Không có gì chắc chắn gà dụ mình ông Quỳ
tôi nhưng mà cũng thể biến mất bước cùng
nào làm Chưa có gì chắc chắn đâu Ờ
thế nhưng tôi vẫn cảm thấy nào ạ là may
mắn hơn kìa mình đã nhìn được cái con
đường mình đi sáng sủa hơn rồi sau khi
hồi mà tôi chưa gì trong tay cả
tôi nghĩa là nhiều ông vào đây cũng đang
cơm mùi như tôi thôi đấy làm chính mình
mù hơn thì
hết Ông nghĩa là kiểu
chúng ta phải tin cái gì đó với tuổi có
vào đấy trừ khi mày ông đang đại gia thì
con nhà người ta có sẵn tiền xong rồi
giỏi sẵn rồi giờ không ngồi đây nghe tôi
nói chém to lâu rồi ông béo đang mù mờ
của cái tương lai của mấy ông em mấy ông
dễ kia
Tôi xem tôi xem ở kiểu gọi là
anh cũng chiếm kiếm một chút hi vọng tôi
nghĩ thế
anh ở đấy tôi có hai bi dao Tôi mới xem
thấy anh nhớ nhầm mình năm nay và nhà
nhiều tiền mình chọn ngành nào để cả hai
tôi chuẩn bị ông xem thử nhé
chị xem video to hơn không
Ừ cái này hiện nó không cho tao Hùng đây
cùng thầy ơi nhớ nhà mình năm nay và nhà
nhiều tiền thì mình chọn ngành nào đây
thầy đây là câu hỏi rất nhiều bạn hay
thử hỏi đó là chúng ta sẽ chưa biết chọn
cái nào cho được về phía bạn chọn ấy
ngành nghề mà nhiều tiền thì bạn sẽ dễ
dàng từ bỏ khi một các ngành khác nó
nhiều tiền hơn em hiện tại từ khi bắt
đầu chọn nghề của bạn nên lưu ý là chúng
ta dựa trên 3 yếu tố một là cái ngành đó
theo nhu cầu thị trường Thứ hai là mình
phải đam mê để đủ đảm bảo là chúng theo
đuổi nó một thời gian lâu dài thứ ba là
dựa vào năng lực của bản thân bạn thì
bạn phải căn cứ vào số đó Để mình chọn
cái ngành nghề nó phù hợp thì khi bạn
trọng cái nghề mà mình đam mê thì mình
sẽ tạo rất nhiều giá trị và khi quan tài
được nhiều giá trị thì bạn sẽ kiếm được
rất nhiều thu nhập từ cái những giá trị
đó bằng tạo ra bạn quan tâm là ngày nào
hãy chia sẻ với chúng tôi nhưng với nhé
Thầy ơi giữ nhà mình đam mê và nhà nhiều
tiền mình chọn
video của tôi gọi điện nó nói qua về
việc học kiểu khi chúng ta phải cân nhắc
với việc chọn ngày đã hư giờ nó
làm cái video này nữa bây giờ dài hơn tí
này họ Tương Tư Người ấy khóc nhìn ekip
không phải vòng tay động lực keep Moving
forward mà mình đang leo này mà làm vòng
tròn ý kia gai sẽ chỉ cho ta thấy bí
quyết để tạo nên một cuộc sống viên mãn
khi công việc ta làm hội tụ đủ 4 yếu tố
điều bản trích yêu thế giới cần điều mặt
được trả tiền và điều bạn giỏi để tìm ra
được ngay công việc có 4 yếu tố này sẽ
rất khó nhưng dễ thấy gần như khi bạn
thích công việc nào đó thì bạn sẽ có
động lực để biến nó trở nên giỏi và Hầu
như các công việc được trả tiền thì thế
giới đều cần nên tạm thời mình ko lại có
hai câu hỏi để trả lời đó là công việc
mà bạn yêu thích hoặc công việc bạn được
trả tiền là gì chúng ta luôn muốn được
làm công việc mà mình yêu thích nhưng
lại luôn bị cuốn hút bởi những công việc
nhiều tiền điều này càng làm bạn mông
lung giữa hai lựa chọn này hơn nó khó
những việc bạn nhắm một mắt hai tay
không tìm cho bạn và đâm 2 ở cạnh nhau
vậy bạn sẽ phải mất rất nhiều công sức
để thử đi thử lạ và bỏ lỡ nhiều thứ hay
ho khác trong cuộc sống thì có một cách
sẽ giúp bạn nhanh tìm được điểm ID của
đời mình hơn đó là trước tiên hãy cứ
chọn lấy một công việc có thể trả tiền
cho bạn hoặc hỏi kiến thức kỹ năng và
thái độ để nâng cao giá trị bản thân
dưới khi đủ lông đủ cánh bạn có thể tìm
được công việc mà mình yêu thích đừng
đợi đến khi tôi tìm được việc yêu thích
thì tôi sẽ cống hiến hết mình mà hãy
cống hiến hết mình đi rồi sẽ tìm ra được
việc mình yêu thích vì tiền chúng ta
nhận được là xã hội trả cho kết quả của
ta mở ra mà nó không quan tâm ta có
thích nó hay không cá bắt đầu từ những
công việc trả tiền cho bạn nỗ lực làm
thật giỏi rồi dần dần bạn sẽ tìm tia
được điểm ID của mình chọn nghề dưới góc
nhìn like ờ
gà trống hay video vào rồi Tôi thấy -
301 thật nhau lắm và cũng đều nói việc
là cậu chọn ngành nghề như thế nào gần
ôm Vân bấm như các bạn hỏi tôi về việc
tôi lựa chọn ngành nào hay ạ Nên Theo
lịch trình vân vân mà không nhiều cái
thì
Ừ cái việc mà tôi chỉ nói là ai cũng nên
học lập trình theo kiểu học để cho biết
còn cũng không bao giờ nói rằng ai cũng
đi theo ngành này bởi vì nó còn liên
quan rất nhiều yếu tố là một trong những
yếu tố đó là Kiều ngày nào cũng có cái
khó khăn của nó thì
nhưng mà không yêu thích nó thì ông sẽ
không chịu khó khăn cái thân thế à Thích
được cái khó khăn nó là sử là sự như tôi
nãy tôi thích tạo độ khó thế thì có gì
thử thách này nó lại phù hợp chẳng hạn
thế Tôi thích kiểu dạng mà
Ồ Tôi thích ngồi máy tính nhiều cái
nhiều cái nhiều người ở không thích ngồi
nhiều người đi lại hơn là anh rất nhiều
cái
nhưng mà nhưng tôi đã nói là tôi tôi may
mà năm nhất tôi à
cho tôi được đi trải nghiệm đồ làm đủ
nhiều ngành nghề để tôi cảm thấy à Ừ Mấy
ngày nay không phù hợp với mình ờ và may
mà tôi kiểu dạng mà vẫn vẫn còn đừng có
gia đình hỗ trợ để mà ăn học nên là
thoải mái hơn về gần đây tài chính theo
kiểu là không bị gánh nặng lắm
đương nhiên là hồi mà tôi đi thực tập
tôi mới bắt đầu xảy ra gia đình cũng bắt
đầu không Mỗi một cái chính rồi lúc đấy
mạng cũng may là tôi được là lại trường
này mà làm cũng kiếm thêm thu nhập vân
vân trong thời gian để lại ngồi học thêm
đấy
Ừ anh Trung Hà ở may mắn Tôi cảm thấy
tôi là con người rất là may mắn rất
nhiều người bảo tôi giỏi vân vân Tôi cảm
thấy mình chẳng giỏi cả giỏi theo khái
niệm giỏi với tôi và còn nhà người ta
thì kiểu học Học ít hiểu nhiều thôi học
một kiểu 10 giờ gì đó tôi tôi chỉ học
tôi học 10 sẽ là tôi nhớ được năm sáu
rồi ôn lại mày là được sáu bảy gì đấy
chứ Tôi cũng không phải người nghe và
phát hiểu hết mọi thứ
Ê Hồi đấy tôi học ở trên trường không
gọi lắm mà
không nói đâu hồi cấp 2 cấp 3 tôi
được đứng
Em có muốn có hồi tôi được đứng top lớp
nhưng mà chẳng qua cho mày được cái nó
lười thôi chứ gà mình cũng chẳng hạn ở
giỏi hơn bọn nó có lấy cấp 3 đứng nghĩa
là mình cố gắng thế nào không thể hơn là
những thằng con nên người ta đấy nhờ tôi
vẫn may mắn là tôi vào được cái môi
trường tôi yêu thích còn nhiều bạn của
tôi thì không anh phải ra các bạn đấy bị
bỏ lại tụt lại phía sau lại bị nạn mà
Vân
Ừ nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là ờ ai rồi sẽ chọn
được đúng con đường mình thôi
ờ ờ
gọi nhỡ học đại học xong phải đi nghĩa
vụ thì mình có bị tổn Hậu không cái câu
hỏi này chính anh em trong new team Hồi
trước ở từng ngồi ngồi ăn rồi trao đổi
vụ này thật ra thì ở
Ừ
thứ nhất là tôi là một con khá là yêu
nước và tội cảm thấy là mình có nghĩa vụ
trách nhiệm nên là mình không không thể
làm thấy cái gì khó con yêu mình
mình cũng trốn chạy nó phải vân vân mình
mình có quyền lợi nghĩa vụ mà cái đấy
gọi là nghĩa vụ mà để mình sẽ không nên
chơi nhánh mình đi
về cái việc mà bạn hỏi là có Tôn hậu hay
không thì nó sẽ tuổi thọ không phải mỗi
công nghệ
cài đặt chuông rất nhiều thứ khác mình
sẽ phải đánh đổi rất nhiều thứ nhưng mà
bé gọi đánh đổi không phải bị mất đánh
đổi tất cả mình sẽ đổi lại những cái thứ
gì giống như là tôi vừa nói là tôi nhiều
người dại như thế là
tại sao mà mất thời gian đi học thế mà
khi thì đi làm luôn cả bạ họ vẫn chưa
Tại sao năm nhất lại đi làm lao động
chân tay thế mà khi không đi thực tập
Luôn bây giờ thế
Ừ thì tôi vẫn nói đấy Đó là chúng ta
phải phải làm tất cả những thứ khác để
mà mình cảm thấy thế nào phù hợp với
mình cũng như là mình sẽ học hỏi được
nhiều kỹ năng nữa chứ không phải ở cả
đời chỉ rán vào mỗi công việc của mình
nó hơi bị cuộc sống nó sẽ bị tẩy nhạt
mấy ông hiểu nếu đi rất là Na nó sẽ cho
thêm rất nhiều trải nghiệm khác tôi tôi
thấy à rất nhiều người trước khi đi sẽ
nói những cái câu không hay còn sau khi
đi thì tất cả không phải là bị tẩy não
là gì cả mà sau khi đi rồi thấy tất cả
mọi người đều nói cho cậu nó mới trải
nghiệm khó quên Và thậm chí còn muốn ở
lại nữa chẳng hạn nó nó tăng cho mình
rất nhiều cái tính tính và nó rèn mình
nên con người của mình
Ý tôi nói thật là tội chưa được đi chưa
được đi bởi vì là tôi à cũng có bệnh nên
nó không đi được còn nếu mà có cơ hội
cho tôi sẽ đi bởi vì à Tôi cảm thấy là
tôi cũng bị bỏ mất cả cái
em Chỉ cái trải nghiệm
sống nội trú ở trường đại học bởi vì tôi
tôi Nhà tôi trên chính phụ Nhà tôi ở
thành phố mà tôi không không phải thuê
trọ cái gì cả nên cũng không được trải
nghiệm cái nội trú nhà tôi thích cảm
giác đấy nói thật là tôi thích cảm giác
rồi tôi thích muốn rửa cảm ta kiểu thiếu
thốn rồi sống cùng anh em sinh viên các
từ thứ nó sẽ có tên gọi đang đúng rồi
đấy nhưng mà nó sẽ vui đúng không anh
nghĩa là thế cùng khổ cùng nhau vui mà
nếu không mấy ông Nghĩa là khổ không vui
không
Mình mình khổ mà tất cả người khác sướng
thì thì mình mới tự tin mình có vấn đề
còn nếu tất cả cũng khổ với nhau thì tôi
chấp nhận cái đấy Chẳng sao à Ờ
anh ngắm mà nói chung là miễn là bạn
không bị gánh nặng về tài chính các từ
thứ nhiều cái thôi chứ ví dụ cho sự kiểu
Ý mình là con một trong gia đình gì đó
mà mình phải nuôi các em nhỏ nhọn còn
rất nhiều vấn đề nữa nghe tôi không để
khuyên Cụ thể một người là nó được nhà
đang nói quan điểm của tôi về nghĩa vụ
quân sự thế
có nhiều người hiểu quyết trốn tránh nó
thấy nghĩa ở đấy một cái từ không tốt
Bởi vì tất cả mọi người từ Khuyến tháng
như hai người làm đúng không
ờ ờ
anh admin Tony cô Dạo thì nghĩ anh đấy
là người thế nào ạ
mà tôi từng nhà
552 của tôi
cho từng một quyển sách của anh đấy là
tội đập 13 của anh đấy
tôi lại không theo dõi anh ấy nữa không
Không nhớ tôi thời gian nào nhưng mà cái
cách nói chuyện của anh đấy à lúc đầu
rất là thoải mái tự nhiên ra đến bây giờ
vẫn thế nhưng mà về sau tôi thấy là kiểu
chắc không phù hợp với tôi nữa
Ừ nó kiểu
trẻ làm tôi cảm thấy không phù hợp tới
nữa thôi anh đấy hướng đến thì lại không
phải là người à
Chỗ rạn là người có 5 ký hiệu dội mà
hướng đến những bạn Nhập Môn giống như
thời tôi bảo lại nó nhất 52 thì ngay
giữa phù hợp còn về sau rồi Tôi cảm thấy
là à
vì nó không ổn với tôi thôi nên tôi cũng
không không biết làm thế nào
cho
tôi tôi dạy về view vẫn cản nhắc Z đúng
không Tôi tôi tôi đang làm về nước xí ở
trên công ty nhưng mà thật ra là tôi chỉ
đi cốt nói thẳng kiểu cách học của mình
ấy Nó là kiểu dạng là nhờ vào những cái
dự án thực tế xong rồi Kiểu
dù có cố tuổi tham khảo code của những
người đi trước mà mình cũng thể học hỏi
được
Ê bà đâu nhà đọc thêm tài liệu nữa nhưng
mà đấy đã đủ làm thôi chứ tôi chết tôi
đang sắp tới đang sắp bắt tay vào làm từ
đầu đến cuối một cái đồ án đèo nắp để
tôi học chưa bây giờ thì ra tôi chứ
chuyện với nó để tôi cậu ra khi vào công
ty
sau khi vào một công ty sáp vì ông sẽ bị
quá tải để mà học nên là thấy Nga cũng
không thời gian học lắm nó khác với công
ty kiểu đã ổn định rồi con gì ổn định
rồi thì ông có dư dả thời gian hơn để
ông và tự học tự nghiên cứu thêm nhiều
cái nữa còn còn đi xa thì ông có rất
nhiều việc giờ cũng không thời gian để
mà học nghề nào thấy ra công ty sáp nó
thường hay tuyển những người có nhiều
năm kinh nghiệm hơn
khi sex
à à
Ờ Ờ nói chung là tâm sự xong rồi Câu hỏi
thì hôm trước thì tôi có chia sẻ mấy ông
về cách
về một vài cái rồi nhau hôm nay đầu đầu
tiên là tôi bảo với ông à Là
bây giờ tôi sẽ dạy mấy ông về level 8
chứ không phải là radio chín nữa bởi vì
ở tôi truyện 18 hơn không chưa thử qua
tới 9 đã thấy nó có vẻ vài cái mới rồi
mà lẫn cả là nó là P8 nữa sẽ có rất
nhiều cá ấy
còn nhiều về mới nữa
khi nghe tôi nghĩa Tôi sẽ dạy cho mấy
ông cho chắc cú cho nó bài bản nhất cho
tôi chuyên nhất thì nó sẽ leo 8 nhá sau
đó thì về sau thích thì mấy ông có hẹn
người xanh chín nó chỉ thêm cái mới nó
cũng không xóa mình cái cũ đi đâu nghe
kiến thức đấy có nghĩa mấy ông đi làm
vẫn ngồi ở
đi theo tôi địa chỉ ông vài phím tắt của
cái việc viết ở trong cmd lại bế tôi một
con người lười Tôi sẽ chỉ ông những cái
phim bắt ngoài việc làm thì ông có thể
cài đặt ở đây mấy ông thể tạo gõ tắt con
nói không biết cải tạo gõ tắt như thế
này những cái ứng dụng gõ tiếng Việt cho
đều hỗ trợ có tắt nha
Ừ nhưng mà còn nếu mà cậu bạn ở trong
câu lệnh thì sao thì
anh em có thể mở cái số 1 ở đầu tiên thì
tôi cái này bạn thân cái này cmd của tôi
đúng không Chị nợ thư mục mới lên này Ừ
cái cmd
Komodo
sôi ấn vào con fix này rồi ấn vào cài
user Asiad này mấy ông có thể edit with
Notepad + + này hoặc status Tomy tuổi
thì hôm trước tôi làm một cái kiểu như
này được thay vì các bạn phải gõ lệnh
dài petition sau đằng sau cái gì đó thì
tôi sẽ thay nó bằng cái A chẳng ạ Các
bạn hoàn toàn thể dán thêm nhiều cái nữa
là sự là
thức ra còn nhiều cái nữa trả tôi sẽ
chia sẻ dần mấy ông sao
nhé bây giờ thay vì mỗi lần gõ dạy vẽ
sân để mà make một cái gì đó như thế này
đúng không thì tôi sẽ là cách ga nha mấy
một cái gì đâu mà anh ơi đói người ông
sẽ thấy da nó sẽ kiểu mình cốt trong bia
người khác nhìn hơi khó hiểu những gì mà
mình sẽ tôi bảo tính của tôi nó sẽ
làm những việc gì nó nó tối ưu hơn hiệu
quả hơn ăn này Ừ tôi sẽ chia sẻ những
cái điều đấy cho mấy ông và hồi mà tôi
đọc được để cho mày biết được và rất
nhiều lập trình viên cũng kiểu dùng lệnh
tắt thở như thế trứng và là kiểu
Lê Minh dung đánh cả
kệ ông ở ông thay lâu làm ra cái level
này không phải làm ra mà nói chung và
mới được
áo kiểu dạng phao đơ trước thì ông ấy
cũng dần dùng rất nhiều phím tắt cảnh
như trong đó có cái A là vòng TP Edison
đấy
mà mất nick đó
Hồi nãy mẹ không ai được alo
à à
A8
A8 có
A8 có thay đổi 670 cái này cho làm các
bạn tra rồi tội có rất nhiều cái mà kiểu
tôi hồi ấy tôi đọc cái bảng so sánh kiểu
thằng này nó thay đổi gì cho thằng cũng
có nhiều cái Hàn cho con không vỡ rồi
tôi không biết không nhớ gì cả ờ Ok và
tiếp theo một cái hepl những cho là để
buổi sáng nữa tôi chỉ với ông bởi vì à
Cái này nó là để hỗ trợ cho chính video
này để nó gợi ý cho mấy ông về cốt có sự
thứ sẽ là ngon
nghe nói chung hôm nay mình sẽ vào bài
nhá Thì hôm nay đầu tiên thì tôi muốn
làm là làm 2 bảng trước
mình mình sẽ có bảng như mấy ông bảo là
mình đến để tiếng Anh đúng không Mình sẽ
tôi tạm dốc này đi ạ
anh ta đi
he He really fast cũng được mật khẩu
Okay
Bố hết hoài à
ở
đầu tiên là database chỗ trống trơn này
tôi sẽ làm à
ờ ờ tôi tôi sẽ làm là tạo 2 bảng là bạn
lớp vào bảng sinh viên như để tiếng Anh
thì có một sự thật là nếu không để nó là
class class tên của Clash of Clans được
nè Tôi sẽ để tên bảng lớp và khóa nhé
khóa học đấy có nóng à cost à Đây này
make model này
cost như thế này không không phải không
thêm không thêm ép nhé không phải là số
nhiều Xong rồi ông có thể
m là mai Vision này và C controllo này
à còn gì nhỉ
cách chữa của tôi sẽ dậy trong mấy ông
hiện nay
Ừ thôi tôi sẽ để an đi tất cả sau đó thì
tôi sẽ dạy cho mấy ông hết toàn bộ những
cái kia sao
a16 - ở một giờ chưa say ta đã được nè
em à cái này cái này đang báo là mình
phải CD đến à quên quên quên quên Tại
sao tôi gõ trong Windows file nhỉ
Ừ đấy quên quên mất đó
với những bạn nào mà không trước Lỡ cài
nào đẹp chín rồi thì các bạn ạ sẽ phải
vào Dock của thằng layer chọn phiên bản
8 sau đó thì sau đó thì chạy cái lệnh
này nó sẽ ghi là cái biểu tượng mà là
biểu tượng miễn là trên 8 là được nha Mà
đầu đầu nó là cái đầu nói cái đầu nó là
8 đấy ông sẽ cài cái này và Nhưng mà
trước khi cài cái này thì mấy ông nên
phải cập nhật lại cậu cái composer của
mấy ông có mưa rơi mà Mấy ông hôm trước
và chọn cái pp phiên bản là 8 chấm Nóng
ạ bây giờ sẽ cài phiên bản khác là sử
dụng như của tôi nữa Tôi
Em mua rồi
ừ ừ
em nói chuyện nghe này mày ông sẽ chọn
lại cái 7.4 ở trong cái thư mục và vẫn
là thư mục của la con thôi và pin rồi
ở tp chọn pp 7.4 chọn này tôi nách là
được sau đó chị mới ông sẽ phải reset
lại cái cmd này sau đó thì các bạn có
thể gõ pp chữ v này
bộ sạc Luân
không ngờ tôi nhớ ở tôi chọn lại còn mu
giờ tôi chọn 7.1 kệ cái đi mà nó cả cái
thứ Hai mày Ông cần làm nữa đó là mày
ông phải chọn kể tới về đây rồi chọn
version nó là 700 40 lại 8 chấm giống
như trước nữa cái bệ PB này tôi không
nhớ là bệnh như tôi cả hôm trước thì
phải cái này mặc định nếu mà ông chạy TP
bình thường nó sẽ thế thôi nhưng mà còn
chạy compose nó vẫn sẽ tải ông Tám chưa
mà cái cái cái chín đâu nhé
ở hiện đại thay thế thôi Bây giờ ông sẽ
chạy TP artisan
make này mua đồ đây có
anh em ngon
à à Mày tới ở ô tất cả tất cả thì nó sẽ
tặng mua đồ này Factory mì cay những
những cái nhỏ lẻ khác thì tôi xin phép
nói sau bây giờ mình chỉ quan tâm có mô
đồ migration và Kenzo l'eau đấy như thế
Ok chưa
ừ ừ
ạ Bây giờ tôi sẽ vào viện này đầu tiên
mình xem.ao B trước mày xin tạm xóa đúng
rồi đi về tôi mới tạo lại cái forex nên
nó hiển thị lại mấy cái micro trên cũ
ở lại mặc định bảng mạnh sẽ ra thêm chữ
ass hiệu xuống nhiều đúng không
anh ở đây sẽ có 2 cột 1 cột là
một con lợn hay đi tự động tăng giống
như hôm trước là vẫn là kiểm tra đó là
kiểu BIG in tất cả số số in số lớn theo
kiểu lưu được nhiều hơn và nó tự động
tăng đi
a tiếp theo là 2 cột là quyết tất update
người không có thể tốt nhất để lại không
cho vào tùy
à Tôi nghĩ là để lại nó sẽ có hai của nó
như là tôi sẽ để lại cho bé ông đi mày
mày không quen
vì nó có cái hay của nó đấy Cùng lắm là
về sau làm thì không có thể nó không cần
cột áp đặt Vì vốn ở Tôi thấy cột mày ít
dùng này bé có người để cột này ở lại
được này à
đã bảo tôi không ngờ tôi nhớ không lầm
là thằng live em nó sẽ hỗ trợ cho mình
vụ là nó tự động mà tự động
số tự động truyền vào trong tháng này
chứ không phải là thằng này
Ừ chứ không phải là mình lưu lại trong
DB đây tôi thử nói qua bộ đấy
đây tôi có thể hiểu chạy nhé
Trinh lại nêm rằng ạ và unic là sửa cho
là duy nhất này chẳng ngon rồi tôi chạy
thử về lạnh sẽ là
I my friend I
à À database không phải là leo đúng
không sửa lại cái này cho tôi bây của
tôi bây giờ sẽ ra school này
họ trả lại
mô
tả lại này
chú ý tôi muốn nói ở đây này nếu không
thấy là hai cột mà nó sẽ có nhưng mà nó
sẽ thứ nhất ở được cho phép Mun vậy Lúc
đầu có thể chấm Thứ 2 là nó không có
defo Nó thường tôi không thích kiểu này
Tại sao vì tôi muốn cho nó cái BPhone là
kiểu dụng là đều là một cái gì đó
anh như kiểu là compare timestamp thế
này Sao lại ta là nó sẽ tự động điên
thời gian hiện tại khi mỗi khi mày
Insert một thằng mới vào tưởng như này
nó sẽ tiện hơn
Ừ chứ không phải để cho thằng Cốt nó làm
đâu đấy
Em hãy để DB làm điều đấy nhưng mà cái
này chắc là có lý do của nó thì vì sao
mình thích thì mình thì sửa lại cái cái
default lấy
Ừ ok Bây giờ mình mình xong cái tao bây
rồi bây giờ mình giờ sự là mình muốn làm
như thế nào Bây giờ mình sẽ Tôi muốn nhá
đó Khi mà tôi vào trang này tôi gõ chữ
cost như này cho nạ thêm chữ f nha đi
thì nó sẽ hiển thị ra toàn bộ những cái
á khóa học của tôi thì sẽ làm như sau
xe ô tô sự thêm Hóa khóa lập trình nhà ở
em ở nhà ông ấy nó không tự động Điền
đúng không Bây giờ rõ ra nó defoe là nên
để cho chồng nó đấy đây tôi sẽ vào bên
router này web này
anh xóa lên cái yêu kệ nó đúng không
Mình sẽ
Ừ mình ở đây mình sẽ có cái như này
router này ghét mày có
thế này
thì mình sẽ gọi điện à Thằng cost
controller này à
ở
nhatrang hạn grab Sau đó chạy đến Hà
miếng đất của nói ý
ở mỹ nghệ choàng ngắn hơn này
Ừ nó
ạ Bây giờ mình nhớ đến hàm index mấy ông
sẽ thấy đoàn khi mà chạy cái có lệnh Ô
kìa nó sẽ tạo sẵn cho mình một cái tăng
cho lo và nó sẽ có tất cả những cái Hàn
như sau Index này tính đã cả để mà Hiển
thị danh sách này led để hiển thị do for
để thêm mới này store để mà lưu lại cái
đấy lưu lại thì mày in-shop thôi sau để
hiển thị ra cụ thể một thằng nào đó này
ed để sửa một thằng
update còn đề sửa một thằng đúng không
mà đi trôi để xóa lang thang ở ngay
ờ ờ mà Thậm chí nó có men mình rất rất
nhiều cái như này đúng không và yêu cho
mình thêm một vài năm nữa tôi sẽ nói cụ
thể kỹ sao ra xử là bởi vì nó đã yêu cho
mình hội cái này rồi nên hoàn toàn mình
có thể truyền ở đây ví dụ data nhé ạ Có
cái này ghép được lấy tất cả về chẳng
hạn for Return về cái view
code này chấm Index ngay mình sẽ hiểu là
mình có một thư mục như này mà có cái
file ngay mà mình sẽ truyền thêm vào đây
là ta ta
ta ngay chỗ này tôi sẽ luôn phải thằng
cuối này nên mấy ông nhớ Bởi hôm trước
tôi nói đó là bởi ông sẽ
Ê mày ông lên à Kiểu chóng mạng bị hôm
nay Phải ngay để về sau mấy ông thể opti
kết cái dữ liệu lên nhưng lại rất tiện
đảm bảo cái lỗi gì đó nó lộ nó thường
hay ở đây nó hiểu là sẽ trả về một cái
là kiểu winsport này là theo kiểu của
api tôi không trả về kiểu này thôi bỏ đi
nó sẽ không báo lỗi nữa
thì ở đây tiếp theo là cái báo lỗi của
cái thằng này nhưng tôi đã bảo hôm trước
để mà Mấy ông tranh báo lỗi này thì béo
không thể dùng hàng Paris như thế này nó
sẽ không báo lỗi nữa thì ra nó vẫn chạy
nhé cho tôi lưu phải tôi già đến ngay
thôi
à à
a cho tôi sẽ tạo ở đây sẽ là tạo cái
đi xuống đúng không tại Sói Điên à
à à
ừ ừ
ở đây mình sẽ còn thấy bồ này
th
ai đi nè nêm này
là sự thế thêm mấy cô kia nữa cũng được
hôm sau à Mấy ông cứ tìm hiểu trước rồi
không sao tao sẽ chỉ cho mấy ông già sự
ra sự là tôi muốn xóa cái cột Tôi không
muốn giữ cái cột à Ờ ăn đi tất nữa Tôi
chỉ muốn giữ cột à class tất thì làm như
thế nào nhé Thì ông thử thử trả lời câu
nhé Hoa quên người quên được dùng vẫn
còn dùng quen từng cái cũ để mình sẽ
dùng cách này đúng không
sẽ tiện hơn này à
Mình dùng Blade rồi mà
họ tích tại ta đi em ạ và đây sẽ là
cố lên em ạ à à
Anh tên lửa kỹ thuật ấp ủ
Anh ở mình sẽ có
l1100 này
nó sẽ trông như thế này không ạ
Vậy thật ấy có phải là không ra xem Tại
sao đây alo cho nó nun là nó không ra
rồi là sử mình cho nó một khoảng thời
gian như thế này sẽ ra trông ngay nhưng
mà cái này nó không dễ làm cho con người
không ạ thì mới ông thật ra mấy Có thể
dùng hạt những cái Hàn của pp format
hoặc lazaro nó cũng hỗ trợ là pho mát
pho mát à đến như thế này
Ê bà nó có cái hàm của nó rất là hay
Em hãy kẹo kẹo như này
à Tôi nhớ là có có cái gì hả pho mát
for Woman the
dead có cái hàm tên tên là giữa hai như
thế này
ở đây
ngày 20 ngày thử cho mình xem nha
không copy được này à
à à
em ở nhà
Ừ cái ha mà đi for Woman này cái gì đó
cậu đã đã tạo Deep này tớ cảm chị lại -
Văn Cơ
ừ à Nó chỉ có this for Woman thôi không
không có kiểu hiển thị ra kiểu dạng
trong kiểu khác à
à à
I was able này
khi nào em chỉ hỗ trợ cho cái vụ kiểm đi
thôi còn nếu mà muốn hiển thị ra kiểu
ngày tháng đẹp thì chả chơi thì cậu cách
này cũng được
em copy về thôi à
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ cái kèo nhà chồng sẽ đẹp hơn này
có nhiều cách
vì nó có pho mát
Dạ vâng Em nhớ thằng cácbon thì nó sẽ có
format nhé nhưng mà đây nếu các bạn mùi
tra thêm về cách mở phòng lao xử lý cái
biết thì nó sẽ có kẻ Thư viện của nó
thương bụng thư viện carbon để mấy ông
xử lý với ông đọc trên cái chai một nó
Ừ anh ở trang này nói kiểu ngay nói
format nó rất nhiều kia
a red light đầu tiên khởi tạo này sau đó
thì nếu có thể hiển thị ra như thế nào
đấy nhưng mà cái này mới không thể đọc
kỹ hơn nhé á
bài
hát nếu không có anh gọi cho cậu kia em
Em chưa thử kiểu kia cơ Em thử lại nhé
à à
khi format
ừ ừ
đồng
hồ Nếu như mà thờ ga thì đây là một
trong những cái kiểu
thì tại sao gọi Cacbon hỏi nó hơi ờ
ở đây là 100 những kiểu mà nó hỗ trợ
nhưng mà ngoài ra nó còn có thể như tôi
đã bảo thì thực ra mình không nên xử lý
phần mấy cái xử lý này ở bên giao diện
mình có thể như tội tâm bạn mình có thể
mình có thể một là xử lý cái này trong
mua đồ đúng ạ ở trong câu trả lời thường
mình sẽ xử lý cái này cho mua đồ nhé Còn
nhớ không ạ Tôi sẽ thử cho béo nhé
có phải tặng xóa hai điểm A
Ừ thì nếu mà Mấy ông muốn xử lý cho mua
đồ thì mày không sẽ Cha Cha ngay trong
cái tài liệu deli là format
nghỉ ở đâu cast đây
cha
mẹ bé ông sẽ có thể là cho cho nó quy
ước Nó là một cái cach tức là cho nó ký
ức là một cái kiểu dạng như nào đó thế
này tí nhé đó như này cũng sẽ copy Dạo
này
cột Quét tất của ông nó biết tha mà Nó
kiểu như này
sau khi ông in doubt sẽ không cần loạn
kia nữa
giống nhỉ
a Cash đúng không
cho mình nhớ cache của mình
Ừ nó để mình xem nhé
em là ca sĩ nhớ lưu lại thì phải chứ
không phải để mà nhập để mày in ra hả
Vậy ạ
các nhóm lần các để lưu lại rồi như thế
không dùng cho cách này à
thế hả
Có một sự thật và anh chàng chuyên bắt
lỗi tôi rồi chị thì phạt tiền
để anh ấy hôm nay với dự tao cái
tao để để xem lại vụ này các
à À đúng rồi Casa để lưu lại thôi nó xét
mà ghét ghét ta thì chắc là mình sẽ dùng
cái
Anh dùng cái hộp format kiểu như vừa rồi
hoặc là hoặc hoặc là mình
mình tôi nhớ có chỉ với ông rồi cái mu
Tây tồ mà cả anh xem show rồi mà ghét
kiểu nhá Nó lấy ra bọn mình Thiện lấy ra
một cái gì đó cũng cách sửa sửa mà đi
thường tôi sẽ đổi cả hai lá
tủ bếp grass of chẳng hạn
như này Chipu
Vì sao nói gì ở đây sẽ truyền qua A
à à
Khi
mà mình sẽ sửa lại đây hoa K đơn giản là
kiểu
I get trở lại hiểu lấy tuổi của một cái
gì đó cũng được
à à
I would em Em đang định lấy ra mà
ví
dụ lấy tuổi hay lấy 5 cái gì đó nó sửa
hétia chẳng hạn như thế này thì mình sẽ
là biết
từ đầu tiên Express 2 theo kiểu làm hai
cậu Paypal thì có nhớ nó nói chuyện ngay
lần đầu tiên tạo theo thằng này đã tiếp
theo để pho mát này
khi format sau đó sẽ truyền vào đây
ý nghĩa như thế này chẳng
anh alo nghe bị ngược thì tí nhé
hai
em cả nhà lấy cụ thể ra cái năm để nhận
ạ sau đó đi tôi sẽ lấy ở đây nó sẽ lại
yêu đúng không
đi cái mất này đó sẽ ra kiểu như ai bây
giờ như tôi hôm trước tôi đã bảo nó sẽ
kiểu Đây là ghét và một cái asset nữa cơ
Ừ cái ghét sách dạo này tôi nghĩa ở nó
giống cái cốt cũ hơn là dễ nó dễ hình
dung hơn
khi sex
anh cho em biết được anh có thể cho cách
vừa nãy mà anh sẽ làm kiểu
Transit nó ngon pho mát bây giờ đúng
không Nhưng mà cái này em em chỉ các bạn
rồi nếu mà paper thuần sẽ làm kiểu này
Anh
muốn chạy được không ạ Anh Tuyết Đã đã
format à
cho con Hằng ngày thì theo như các bạn
ấy đang hiểu là nó chỉ là tên chỉ dữ
liệu từ cột đấy thôi Nhưng bản chất
thằng Model là đã biến đổi biến đổi
những nó sẽ đọc hộ cái lốp màn lúc mà
thấy thừa cái quần này họ sẽ đạp hộ cái
dữ liệu sao nó sẽ có format hội trong
mấy ông rồi Nếu mấy ông gọi trợ như thế
này đấy
Con đến mà Mấy ông làm thì cổ p thuần mà
không có thể làm chỗ như này không một
trong hai cách mà ngọn ạ
Ừ Ok Đấy là cách lấy ra dữ liệu
thôi Hơi bị dài dòng tí mình sẽ nhảy
sang bên A bây giờ xử mình thêm dữ liệu
nhà ở
a a
này thêm dữ liệu này
Ừ thì đây
ở
đây mình sẽ có một cái Router đúng không
hôm trước tôi bảo sẽ gọi được Grow tơ
thì mình sẽ có router là cos như thế này
xong rồi press thể hiểu là kiểu
Ừ vậy sao không phải Đã quét tổng như
hôm trước mà thêm chữ có làm gì bởi vì
về sau là mình sẽ có thêm router của cả
thằng tương đình nữa nên là mình sẽ phân
biệt ra là
thêm khóa học này thêm sinh viên Vân Vân
đúng cách để viết cái bài viết cái này
thì tôi sẽ viết thư cảm nha à
khi quét nhà chẳng hạn sau đây sẽ chạy
và Chris này mà mình sẽ lên nó nó
là
cậu ngay nên thằng này thường chấm như
này cơ đấy ông ạ
ea2 không có ép em nhé
À thầy sẽ để của bình thường như thế này
có mỗi trên router rồi mình đến nên để ý
thôi
Ừ nó thì mình bấm vào đây sẽ hiểu là
thêm một cái gì đó
a
tiếp theo là mình sẽ có
có
phải thêm đúng không
blade-empire
format
truyền lên mà nó
ừ ừ
à à
có
thêm chọn mà mình sẽ có Action
toàn thân aichun hàng ngày sẽ là Ừ để
lại tiếp tục ngày đêm Grow tôi đúng
không
là code này
và Store để lưu lại này mấy thơ là
Porsche
và nhựa nói là nếu là fan mấy thớt post
thì mình sẽ phải cầm cfz một cái để nó
chuẩn bị bị hack Hùng gì gì đó
à à
A Bank oriental lại mình sẽ Return về
review đúng không
tủ lạnh tôi sẽ đi tơ trong mấy ông cái
view này à
khi bạn đặt tên Express luôn à
Em có nghĩ có tạm xóa comment đó Thử đi
à à
hôm nay nó sẽ bảo là cái router là chưa
được khai báo thì cái lỗ tơ này Nếu được
khai báo thì lại phải đăng ký kết cái
này lại thay cái này hả
ông ngoại thay cái này lại thay cái này
nó đổi đây là post thì mới Ông thấy nó
sẽ bị bất tiện ở điểm có những cái gì
đang họ Đạo
cái đoạn này nó bị lặp lại khá nhiều này
Ừ cái này nó đang gặp lại này thường mẹ
thường thì sẽ là mình sẽ có khái niệm
motor group như thế này nhóm nó thành
vòng nhóm ông sage là Glass bridge
update Delete xem thêm sửa xóa thì mình
sẽ có nhóm thằng này vào trong một nhóm
như này và mình sẽ có ở đây là như này à
ừ ừ
có khái niệm một nhóm nhảy nhá mình sẽ
có thứ nhất là mình sẽ có Pacific ở đâu
nhỉ ngoài fix đấy mình sẽ free fix Tức
là cái tiền tố Rằng Trước tiên tố là nó
chép mình sẽ truyền vào đó chính là cost
như thế này tiếp theo
ô tô copy toàn bộ dạo này vào đây nhé
ăn uống nghỉ Bích
Ừ đúng rồi phải trả tiền tôi đang trước
thì mình sẽ được phép xóa lại đi này nếu
không sẽ thấy nó ngắn hơn rất nhiều ạ
ở đó như này
à mà không thích thì để kéo nhà cho
chồng chủ nhiệm được tế bào nữa
ờ ờ
a tiếp theo nữa là mấy ông muốn muốn cái
phần mềm này nó đỡ bị đặt Điệp lại cậu
ngay thì mới ông cũng thấy chưa Tiền Tố
Như này
Ừ nó là
areas estefan là có dấu chấm như này thì
béo cũng sẽ được phép Xóa các bạn này đi
này
Chị Đại
à à
thế này nó sẽ giúp rút gọn đi khá nhiều
nếu không sẽ thấy hồi trước tôi nhớ là
hồi TP ở hồi rio5 chấm gì vậy nó còn cho
kiểu toàn bộ với ai có dùng chung một
câu trả lời đúng không Nếu không phải
bảo con trả lời trong này nó khóa sử về
đoạn trả lời được thế rút gọn để dọn Thế
nên à Bây giờ mình cho nó vỡ rồi phải
level 9 thì lại có lại thì phải tôi
không Nhớ lắm Nó hơi buồn cười đấy rõ
ràng hồi đợi tao leo
555 bọn nó bỏ đi thằng gần đây nó được
khôi phục lại vậy là
Nhưng mà đại khái trở như thế nếu không
sẽ thấy rõ à
th2 không wifi
thêm chữ s site đó như thế này không cho
tôi Giả sử gọi điện để quản trị bảo mật
này ạ
lần thêm này
ê ê
xin lỗi em
xin lỗi nhỉ
a cpm1a
em à Cái lỗi này nó liên quan đến cái
bên trong này cơ trong này tôi đâu mặc
định là cái này do tôi đang dùng cái
quét kiểu nhé mày nó viết tôi chưa dậy
mà gửi về hết mình tôi sẽ tạm xa nay đi
rồi sao tôi sẽ chỉ mới uống sau
Ừ cái này sẽ dùng miếng nhớ càng ngày
hôm trước phải dùng cái này phải
tại như thế này cơ
tả lại đó đồ đấy
anh
khóc nếu dùng cái này sai vậy
anh nữa à cái thôi cái này cái này ừ ừ
ở nhóm nhạc à
à à
ô tô loạn quá à đây đây đây
đây đây
nếu mếu không nhớ đôi khi là mấy ông ạ
thế thôi nhớ ở cái catalo ở đây nó có gì
phải làm copy bên này nó nhanh hơn đấy
tôi có một con chó đâu à
Hồi trước và tạo con chữ L mặc định nó
có cái này Đúng rồi em bây giờ nó lại
đổi hết hàng rồi quét kiểu như này nên
hay là không không nhớ
a http này cài sẵn sàng Đúng rồi nằm nhớ
sẽ nhớ à
anh nói kìa anh Minh tĩnh không sao cái
này là cái này Thực ra nếu mình không
nhớ mình có sửa lại cho đúng rồi
Ờ Ờ
nói chung là bây giờ để mình thêm một
cái thì cũng trước mình đã làm do sửa
mình sẽ khởi tạo Nó là sự mình sẽ rõ
check bằng new boss như này cho mình
chuyển toàn bộ thông tin vào sự là mình
sẽ truyền nêm vào như này sau đó request
ghép Nên nha chẳng hạn
ạ sau đó thì con dê
A
gọi đến Hàm xếp để lưu nó lại chẳng ai à
ở nhà mình chạy thử nhé thì nó sẽ có báo
lỗi gì cả và nó sẽ được thêm chuyển ngay
và mặc định tehran nó sẽ nó sẽ kiểu tự
động Điền nó hai cột này mặc định hay
còn này nó sẽ bằng nhau nhưng mà về sau
khi uống sửa cái gì đó thì cái cột này
nó sẽ được cập nhật còn này vẫn giữ
nguyên anh tưởng như thế nhưng như tôi
đã nói từ bụi hôm trước tôi thử hỏi mấy
ông bộ từ bữa ăn chơi và sửa ra cái bảng
này sẽ có mấy mấy cột thì cách cho nghe
nó không hề Tối ưu tạo nào Tại sao thì
nó sẽ gặp lại đây có mười mấy cái thằng
như nay đúng không ạ sẽ không ngồi với
mấy ông tìm hiểu về đấy nhỉ
em kiểm tra kiểm tra bài tập về nhà mấy
ông tìm hiểu cái đấy cho bây giờ sự đã
có có nhiều nhiều dữ liệu cần phải điền
nóng ạ Mình sẽ làm như thế nào để tránh
việc mình phải điền rất nhiều cá như thế
này
được số ít đó
mẹ không đồng ý rồi không phải là đẩy nó
sang một cái lôgic gì đó một vài khác để
xử lý đâu
gà qué tô để lấy tất cả
cũng đúng
I feel ngoại bạn chưa nói với cái phim
đúng nếu mình khởi tạo đối tượng đúng
không ở đây ở đây sẽ có những cách sau
bạn kia mấy bạn kia Nó phiêu cũng là một
cách nếu mà các bạn khởi tạo đối tượng
tại mình sẽ thử chỉ mấy ông các bạn để
xem
nó sẽ cao ngày đầu tiên đi quét lấy tất
cả những cái dữ liệu Mình ở Điền xong
cái phone TOEFL để mà
field có hàng này tức là chị nó sẽ lấp
đầy tất cả những cái theo đúng những cái
truyền vào nhưng cái này có một lưu Yến
một tí đó là trong trường hợp này mấy
ông bắt buộc phải tên của cái file mà
cũng chưa lên phải khớp với cái tên của
cột trong ra đây thì mình mấy ông mới
chơi cái này được nhá để tiếp theo là
mấy ông sếp như thế này chạy thử này thì
nó sẽ báo Cái lỗi này đó là
em tự nhiên ông truyền lên ở đây sẽ có
một cái đó là đây cho bé ông xem này
à à
ở đó mấy ông truyền nhưng ở Cô Tô cân
vào như thế này với mặc định trong phòng
luôn có thói quen em hãy ra là không
không không truyền được Kiểu như thế
Ê
mấy ông dễ thương hay là Triệu access là
loại trừ thằng này đi
anh access Floor in ra luôn
à À ông kia định dùng uống bia á only
nhiều quá thì sẽ xét về loại - ạ à à
I did well thôi nhớ Lara video hay
access gì đó tra thử nhé Phát request
này
Ừ anh à Sẽ loại trừ cái thằng Hò gi I
ô
tô thử sửa nhé
di chuyển ở trong đấy một mạng anh ạ
ở đó sẽ như thế này hình như không cần
phải mạng được
Ừ
nó nếu sẽ loạn chủ thằng này đi như này
thế Mình không muốn lấy cái cột này để
mà Bình Điền vào trong Vì nằm dưới con
này đâu ngoại trừ đi đấy
tiếp theo nó sẽ bảo lỗi này lỗi ở Liên
quan việc là cái này liên quan đến bảo
mật thôi cái thằng uruk là tự động kiểm
tra cho ông cái này để làm sao để mà nó
sẽ cậu mẹ nó sẽ hỏi là cái thế này nó
không nằm trong cái có thể điền được của
cái thằng mua đồ này nữa mấy ông sẽ phải
khai báo những cái có thể điện được cho
mua đồ thì nó mới cho phép Ông làm cái
vụ này cho tôi sẽ ở đây là nhớ cô thích
thì public em xuống nhớ
từ rồi nhé buổi tập này à phia bầu
vào đây sẽ là một cái mạc và những thứ
mếu thể truyền được là số đó chỉ cho mấy
ông truyền là mỗi nên mà chẳng lạ ở nhà
ai
xe tải lại này
Ừ cái này ở
Ừ đúng rồi tôi tả lại trang này nó bị
Dhabi kết cột bảo mật rửa tội thêm như
thế này đó thế là được tại loại này thì
ông sẽ có
từ ngày ok chưa
đây sẽ có 2 cách để mày ông làm một lời
ông thường hay á tôi Tôi tưởng này làm
đã thêm cà phê capo để mà cho chắc chắn
là mình sẽ chỉ cho phép điện Cột nào có
cách thứ hai mà ông là nếu như có bạn
kia bình luận thì nó là là ra được tức
ám chỉ là những cột nào không cho Điền
thì ông sẽ kiểu Dùng cái đấy được có 2
cách để làm anh em mà thường là tôi sẽ
dùng cách này để cho mình từng minh hơn
mày nhìn thấy được là cột những con nào
được cho phép điên thế nên là về sau
mình cũng phải hơi bị sửa một tí khi mà
về sau mình sửa ra tao bay mình cũng
phải phải đi làm thêm ở trong cuộc này
con như bạn kia bảo là k đất thì thức ăn
chỉ ở những cột không được phép Điền Còn
nếu mà giờ sự ra được là trống nhưng ta
cảm thấy mình được phép biến hết ra thấy
nó không hẳn hay lắm Bởi vì có những cột
mình không được phép liền hợp Giống nhờ
cột với thật ấp 2 của đã về thật đúng
không mình mà cho phép người dùng điền
vào cột đấy người dùng có thể giả dụ là
tao đăng ký vào trang của mày nhưng to
giả tạo thành viên lâu năm tôi sẽ bị ta
sẽ tạo thêm cái phim mới tôi điên bà
Không phải kiểu như thế Mày có mình
không
thì tay này tôi thử Cách Của Bạn ơi cho
mình xem nhé à
anh ở nhà rồi tôi sẽ ấn inspector thường
à người dùng không biết làm cái này đâu
nhưng mà nhiều lóe câu giả sự giả sử
đánh hacker nó chơi với cho lại thích
sao nó sẽ hoàn toàn thể thêm à
có thêm một cái bút nữa nha chẳng hạn
Ừ ở nhà đi 15 phút sẽ gretech
ngày sẽ đến nhà rồi hả
à à
anh
thương em nhạc Đợi tí đã đi à
à à
Em
làm ở lưu lại nhé
à à
anh ở đây ok rồi
chọn ngày này
à à
ở đây mấy ông thế phòng tắm sữa được ký
ngay Nếu mà giờ sử mà Mấy ông cháu không
không điện gì xong cái cốt này thức làm
chuyện mình cho phép Điên hết thì nó sẽ
không một em cách tôi tôi tôi thường hay
thấy ở dùng cái này hơn bằng cách kia
thì nó tiện ở điểm là mình không cần
điền tất cả các cột
anh đúng không
Ừ
ok Bây giờ là thêm rồi này Đây mình sẽ
quay lại thì hôm trước cũng có bạn hỏi
là mình sẽ điều hướng quay lại kiểu gì
mình dùng header location là không Bơ
mình sẽ làm kiểu Return nha chị sẽ luôn
Reuters một cái gì đó bạn nó sẽ điều
hướng ở razak này mấy ông có thể đã ghi
hàng vào đây tên của cái router thì phải
nhớ Thế à
à mà không không ạ
ở đây tả lại chanh nó đã bị đã ký kết
với tí nhé á
anh không không không chuyển được tiền
đâu tôi nó sẽ phải như này
router như này mới đúng
ừ ừ
ở xã cha mày
à Nguyễn nhà đất Hạ đó
Ừ nó bê nó bảo cái lỗi khác này báo lỗi
này là cái router à Chưa được khai báo
không tìm thấy thì mình sẽ vào router
này trong nhà
a web này
à Dạ lên với nó
và Index này
à à
xe tải lại sao tại sao nó lại bị đau bi
kết tiếp rồi
Ừ ok này đó sẽ ngay đây mình có rất
nhiều thằng để test rồi bây giờ sự là
tôi muốn làm mà xóa trước đi
Tôi sẽ làm xóa nó thì mình sẽ đây sẽ
nhảy vào đi cho rồi đúng không để xóa mờ
thằng nào đấy à
Ừ thì tôi ở đây xóa này để Delete a
à à
ừ ừ
Anh
Bình thường mấy ông nhớ là nó sẽ thẻ ở
ngay đúng không Rồi Hz nhớ đến cái gì
đúng không
anh như vừa nãy mình làm chị sẽ Daughter
ngay sao costs ngay rồi nếu đến ít thoy
rồi đi cho ngoài đi lấy đâu nha
cả ngày nay sao mấy ông Nghĩa ta
khi đổi tiền tôi cứ tạo cái cái đầy đặn
nha
sau khi mà ở theo quy tắc của L'Oreal
thì cái thằng này làm mới thoát không
phải boss không phải ghét mà sẽ Delete
ngày cơ mà sẽ đi cho mà nó sẽ cần có
trạng kịch kèm theo một cái mã Tôi sẽ
đặt tên nó cũng là như này luôn chứ
không phải đặt tên Đây là mã không phải
tao tới đây ID nó sẽ là tên nó là cậu
nhà luôn mấy ông sẽ hiểu thì lý do tại
sao
họ để hai mí cho này tên là đi cho này
bà Nếu mà kiểu như thế này thì mày ông
sẽ thấy nó báo lỗi một cái như thế này
nó thiếu cái tham số truyền vào trong
cái router này cách để truyền thông số
này vào thì mới ông sẽ phải như này phải
như này nếu không sẽ có truyền vào là
cost
như này họ đến đôla x tại ID phải hiểu
chứ em vào di chuyển cả đi vào trong cái
code như thế này chạy thử mấy ông nhé
à à mày xóa nhỉ Delete này à à Tại mấy
ông sẽ thấy à trên hàng dừa dưới thay
ngày của tôi đang truyền và kiểu trợ
ngay nhưng mà nhưng mà
vì nó có thể làm tắt hơn người điều này
chị thay cả ngày Thằng Điêu vậy anh có
thể tắt hơn chịu nha nó sẽ đi nhau đang
ở để làm được ngay với điều kiện là cột
cột hóa chính cũng không phải là cột ID
thì mới không sẽ làm được cả tắt kẹo
ngay nhé Còn nếu mà cột quá trình ông là
cụ khác thì tôi không chắc vụ này đâu
nha đấy
anh nghe đấy do tối nghĩa là mấy ông
cũng chuyển dần dần sang hết tiếng Anh
này nó sẽ hỗ trợ thích hợp rất nhiều cái
thuận nha đã anh tiếp theo là mình bấm
vào đây là xóa đúng không
Em bấm vào đây ở Xóa Nếu mà thực ai nó
sẽ báo lỗi như thế này
Ừ nếu mà ông bấm vào một cái đường link
để mà xóa một cái gì đó thì nó làm mấy
rất ghét lại mấy thớt Dielac và cái
method Delete thử ta như hồi tôi dạy pp
thì không có khái niệm mới thoát nào mới
thấy Iraq chỉ có 20 hết mình đã được học
mà biết ghét là mấy thức post thôi cái
làm lòi ra là tuyến mới thôi Đi lên này
bản chất là cái xóa này nó sẽ không làm
cho thẻ ra nó sẽ nằm trong phạm này vào
đây sẽ không phải Hazard sẽ Sun Ah
thế này bạn ấy thốt Làm bài thật tốt cơ
Thế làm thế nào để mình lấy được cái mới
xuất + Delete bây giờ Nhất là cái này nó
sẽ thay một cái nút này Delete này và
thứ hai đó là
đương nhiên là nhờ nhờ ông nó trong for
luôn có sẽ đúng không tiếp theo là mình
sẽ có cái khái niệm năm Mỹ tốt như thế
này và mình sẽ khi Delete vào trong
những loại cơ đó phía tôi ấn cần ẩn
inspect để cho miếng xem nhé Thì bạn
chất nó cái form như này bạn nó sẽ có
hai cái bút hay đặt một cái là cái bút
cho kem một cái input ta chuyển method
cả dưới nước vào thực chất thực chất Cái
thuốc này sẽ Delete ai mà Bây giờ ông ấy
Bấm vào sẽ không báo lỗi gì nữa cái Ở
bên này một xóa thì sẽ là
nó sẽ xóa đi đúng không thì một là mấy
ông sẽ thể chơi theo cách kiểu như này ở
đó là
em có nhiều cách để làm khi mà mới ông
truyền lên đây mà Ông thấy là truyền Lê
nay đi đúng không bà cái đi nó sẽ điều
truyền ở đây này nếu không sẽ ở đây là
có sợ đây
ở đây sẽ là đi choy có như thế này
đi mua đồ gọi đến cái này thằng này ID
truyền Idol có thể chuyển danh sách đã
đi lại được sẽ xóa chạy này nó chạy được
đúng không Nhưng mà thực ra với lâu nó
có rất nhiều cách tách tắt hơn
vì đó là tôi sẽ béo mỉ kĩ là lúc đầu nó
nó gợi ý cái gì có gợi ý chính cái này
cơ Cái này
cái vừa cái cốt vừa rồi đấy cho tôi bạn
sẽ giữ nguyên cho mấy ông mẹ uống hình
dung nhé
lại đi trôi đây đúng không
ngày gì đây là cách viết theo kiểu nó
quay bim đơ như tội từng nói và tôi sẽ
dậy mấy ông cả quay Winner và cả l quần
này quay builder
Tức là sao Tớ làm chỉ là nó sẽ tụ sinh
ra câu ashwell của ông theo kiểu dạng Hà
ông chạy Gọi đến Hà bi-led hai cái gì đó
Nếu có thể là viết theo kiểu ngày nữa
Này Where
ID bằng code như thế này à ạ sau đó đi
Delete ngày cũng được
có ngay kiểu Nga vẫn được hiểu là sẽ xóa
toàn bộ những cái thằng chuyên hãy đi
lên như thế này nhưng mà Đấy trong
trường hợp mà ông ghi có liền như thế
này thì nó sẽ ai đi còn nếu mà ghi hơn
cổng ngay thì tức là sao thế là Lara nó
đang s kiểu cho cái ID này biến thành
một đối tượng và ông Nếu mà béo muốn làm
gì thì cứ tưởng mày thì ông sẽ chỉ cần
gọi như này à
xe tải chở để tôi đi rồi mày ông ấy Ông
xem qua mày không hình dung được Tôi
đang nói cái gì Anh chém gió cái gì nãy
giờ em
ở tại trang này
ở Bà Rịa đi à
à à Xóa xóa mất bạn kia này là nó nó
phao
bấm vào đây này đấy Thằng này sẽ biến
thành một cái đối tượng nếu mà ông ghi
theo kiểu ngày còn lấy vợ ông xã cái này
đi thì nó sẽ chỉ là một số rồi đấy
A và cách 2 của cái Hằng này đó là tôi
thích thì tôi thích dùng cái này hơn Tại
sao Tại sao phải làm dùng theo như thế
này bởi vì nó sẽ kiểm tra hộ cho âm là
thằng này nó nó có chuẩn và nó còn tồn
tại nó còn tồn tại không nó sẽ báo lỗi
hội cho ông ở vụ này thử nhé
i10 đó thằng không còn đúng không
em không có học được Đợi tí nữa chị ạ
à à
chị 100 đi
xe tải nó sẽ báo hộ cho ông là nó không
tìm thời như này đấy còn nếu mà ông làm
hai cỡ này à
em gái đi
à à
Ừ nó vẫn ra được nó ngon nghĩa là thằng
này nó tác dụng là kiểm tra trong cơ sở
dữ liệu hộ ông là thay Đạt còn tồn tại
không đấy một cái giữa hai của nó nó
virus hội cho mấy ông vụ đấy tiếp hẹn
tiếp theo là nếu anh sẽ gọi đến thì cậu
nhớ ai thì đơn giản nó gọi đến Hà
Bitcoin hãy gọi thằng Delete hay gì đó
ngại cũng được nhà được
sẽ hiểu là xóa Mà này họ xong cứ trôi đi
hết rồi không nhiều lắm nha thử nhé
Chắc là nó sao rồi
Ừ ở nhà đi lên đây sẽ hiểu là xóa hàng
ngày
Ê thằng này nó sẽ biến thành đối tượng
và nó hoàn toàn là chạy được những câu
lệnh xóa hay thêm edit hay cái gì đó để
cho bé ông đã tiện mà xong bạn lại mình
sẽ lyrics về điều hướng về đúng không
nha
à à tại trang đấy lỗi rồi Về hai bay rồi
mà này đó nhà để không thấy cốt toàn bộ
tính năng thêm sữa xóa bắt đầu nó cài
càng ngắn dần đâu đúng không Đây Còn đây
là cách mà hội trước khi ông là mà không
Chiều nay đi lên rồi mấy ông sẽ đi trôi
Hoặc là mày không quen như này rồi nó
không đi cho để mà xóa đi đúng không thì
tôi vẫn sẽ giữ khách đấy Ở đây còn cách
của thằng này theo kiểu hướng đối tượng
nó sẽ làm với cậu ngay ngắn hơn ngắn hơn
và nó cũng có tí bảo mật hơn nó sẽ lách
hộ mấy ông để kiểm tra nó có hợp lệ hay
không Nếu hiểu rồi không này
a tiếp theo là mình sẽ làm em đi đi
Ừ cái địt nha à
ừ ừ
Ừ
đúng rồi tôi Tôi biết rất nhiều người họ
pluriel nhưng mà kiểu thực sự không đọc
được tài liệu rất dài ờ ờ
đề tài liệu ở rất là dài và những cái
này những cái mẹo để mà cho nó ngắn gọn
hơn hay là nhiều cái thôi Nhiều người
cũng không đọc cái đấy cũng không tìm
hiểu những cái tắt Bởi tôi hiểu tính tôi
rất thích thấy thấy thằng lao rất là hay
Rất là ngầu lên có tìm hiểu đấy rất là
nhiều nên là nên là tôi cũng đọc được
thêm một vài cái mẹo đấy gọi là Mẹo kiểu
thế
Ừ đúng rồi em biết được là anh vẫn dùng
thằng đi thôi sau khi bây giờ cho cái
kia cái thằng tí cho nó có thể xóa được
nhiều ai đi cùng lúc nhưng mà Đúng là
mình nên là virus cậu như thế này nó bảo
mật
Ừ cái này thì như tôi nhớ không lầm chỗ
gọi kiểu này vẫn chạy đấy
Em thử thử phát nhanh xin phép thử
ông xã gửi cho mẹ
có ai nó không nghe
Ừ
Ừ thế em sẽ không bao giờ
Ừ không thì gọi đi cho rồi làm thì cả
nông dân vậy
15 kiểu gọi điện nói gì nói như này cũng
được mà
chỗ này thì chắc sân bay rồi
anh hả
ở lại một trong hai cách mới có thể tham
khảo nha
Ừ nếu mà kiểu ngay sẽ gọi đến nay đi này
lại cho nghe cho bạn ạ
ờ ờ
anh Thành Nghị sau một tí thon à Người
yêu cũ dùng
à router này bọn đến bây giờ mình sẽ báo
thêm
khi edit ở đây sẽ là ghét này anh sẽ
Adidas này hoặc là update premium ở đây
sẽ là Adidas này
à à
Khi mà mình cũng cầm nên truyền theo ID
nó sẽ ra tên trộm ngay
ý là cost chấm edit và đây sẽ nuoc lại
ra tiền không ạ Cái này sẽ
sớm cái gì đó Em bấm vào đây này sẽ hiểu
sửa cái thằng còi đia10 ạ Ở
đây mình sẽ
A
Happy Kids hàng ngày lên mà đội Dallas
A và khi mẹ đi Ở đây người ông thấy có
cái gì con quê ở đây không mấy ông thay
vì mấy ông kiểu Nếu mà Mấy ông làm nơi
kiểu truyền anh đi lên như hồi trước là
mấy thì mới ông bột là mấy ông sẽ cậu
Kotex như này
E bằng Ờ cost
a file Hà Đông t chỉ những cách của mấy
ông nha sẽ ID rồi ngay à Xong rồi FED để
lấy than đầu tiên ra này
khi phốt là lấy thằng đầu tiên ra không
cần phải mất công két rồi đấy Thằng kiểu
máy ép keo eiffage lấy thằng đầu tiên
nữa với lại lấy xong được tin này nếu mà
nếu mà ông muốn tắt hơn đắt hơn nữa cái
đoạn này nhé Thì ông sẽ làm với cậu ngay
a file như này xong rồi Có ngay có sở
trong trường hợp này nó là ai đi nhé
Ừ nếu mà ghi Dạo này cho trường hợp này
nói đi nhé Còn mấy ông muốn tắt hơn nữa
giống như vừa rồi đã làm đó là bản chất
nó sẽ luôn kiểm tra hộ mấy ông Vũ Như
này thì rõ ràng mà nó đã sẽ lách hộ cho
mấy ông như thế này rồi Nếu không chỉ
đạo Return về review thể hiểu để mảnh
em làm thôi mà Em không cần ghi bất kỳ
câu select gì ở đây nữa nó sẽ chuyển vào
như này
nè xong
nghe xong rồi đổi đây đi này ở đó
anh ạ
anh em đi chứ không cần bởi vì edit hiện
tại nó là mấy thấy ghét để mà kiểu gì mà
sửa gì đó thôi con cái khi mà đẩy dữ
liệu lên thì nó là cần bảo mật cơ mà Thì
lúc đấy mình mới truyền nó là mấy thức
mới thơ Thì đó Những cái Delete này rất
là nguy hiểm này nên mình phải có bảo
mật Đúng không Delete một cái gì ông
Hiệp con khi là để ấn vào để sửa cái gì
đó nó chưa nguy hiểm khi mà ấn gửi cái
thông tin Sửa lên nó lại nguy hiểm thì
mình để trong mấy thức là lại để trong
mấy rất post lại nằm trong cài bom đấy
ạ bây giờ edit mới gì đó thì mình sẽ có
bao lâu rồi đây đôla x chuyên Lê và và
và khi mà sửa đây để update đúng không
ex2 hiểu xưởng xưởng để tham có truyền
ID nào đó cho ông này Đây là thường là
sẽ em bé Thơ là phút để mà sửa cái gì đó
hoặc là bắt nhưng mà tôi thích cái bút
cái này sẽ ra update Họ đã đi cái đi tù
email
update
update này
những kẻ biết ok này bà mê thớt sẽ là
bút ra tôi thích viết hoài đâu rồi mấy
ông biết không biết hoa loại này nó vẫn
chạy nhé
chị đã sửa này À đấy phải để tiếng Anh
hoàn toàn đi ừ
à à
à
À đây khỏi đồ là ít nữa tôi Đổi đổi kia
Đôla có phải
để lại ít đi
Ừ nó ngay chuyển một cái gì đó nha thoải
mái đúng không ạ Rồi tôi là nó biết
bài
hát đêm này nó đang bảo Cái lỗi này nữa
là liên quan việc là đây như tôi đã bảo
nó làm virus hộ tôi nếu tôi không cần
virus rồi xóa đi à
ở cái đoạn này có cái rất hay đó là
à bút hapac điểm nào ạ Cái này chắc em
tra Google thì anh cũng chưa dùng Bác
bao giờ này không biết phân biệt nó nha
Ờ
Ừ cái như tôi đã bảo thì mấy ông một là
tôi lại ghi theo cách 2 cách nhá một lần
bị ông sẽ Nếu là sự không có này Cái này
là ai đi đúng không Thì mới ông sẽ ra
cost như này Where ID
anh Bằng
à à anh có thể gọi điện hay đi nha anh
sao update kiểu nhanh được
à à
anh
access ở đây sẽ là chuyển vào là không
truyền topken
cái này không phải lo cái này cũng chẳng
biết được mình cái kia đâu bỏ qua đi
À ừ nhỉ Đấy tất cả đấy ra 2
em teo cả lắc Cập nhật tất cả những hàng
của Irene ai cập nhật dữ liệu nay tôi
chạy thử mấy ông xem nhé
anh đúng không phải xét thận cách xếp
này à
à à
a
Pokemon à
khi khởi nghĩa ở sẽ ghi cả mày xong với
ông dễ nhìn đi ị
ừ ừ
à à à à
a mã nghệ thuật ở
ở đó không báo lỗi gì cả xem thử nhé á
anh lại lập trình đã biến hàng chữ dài
dằng dặc rồi đúng không Nhưng đây là một
cách
một cách khác thì mày ông có thể là Ê bà
a
cost gọi đến thẳng nhà luôn nó sẽ hiểu
là file cho thằng này vợ lấy hết sửa bạn
như nhau thôi
em có gọi nhạc
Anh Hải à Ừ ông sẽ thấy là kéo nó sẽ
tiện nha à
Ha ha cái này không thể lười được à Mấy
ông Nam nói việc là tôi đang cứ phải ghi
lặp lại cái đoạn access này bị lừa đúng
không Không sao về sau nếu mà như tôi đã
bảo là buổi sau buổi sáng nữa dậy mới
ông phải virus này để kiểm tra những cái
gì mình được phép truyền lên đấy và mình
sẽ có thể dùng cái hàm không phải cùng ô
không phải dụng nó sẽ phải nữa mà mình
sẽ lấy những gái mà đã vay hết vào mình
sẽ chỉ dùng những cái đấy nó sẽ Khái
niệm và request nhớ ai bipad thật như
thế này lại lấy những thằng đã được
virus thì cái này sẽ ra tốt và biết hai
và hết được nghỉ
e3z phải đấy thì phải nói cho bộ hôm sau
mình sẽ biết thì sẽ không cần phải gọi
để lấy xếp thời gọi đến lâu nữa bởi vì à
a a life mình đã từng chọn áo like Nhưng
mà thực ra là mình nghĩ mình sẽ dạy tất
cả Ừ để nguội hôm sau tôi sẽ tôi sẽ tổng
hợp lại những cái mà những thứ tôi sẽ có
thể dạy cho mấy ông đấy ông ạ soạn thành
một cái cậu online một cái mục lục lại
mấy ông thể soạn thảo
ừ ừ
à Mình dùng Facebook rồi thì lúc bảo vệ
thì mình pháo web sao
tôi có thể không chỉ ở mấy ông về
Đúng là Facebook nó hỗ trợ cho bé ông
10fl nhất trên những từ sự thì có đầy
lỗi rồi mặt lôgic nữa mấy ông có thể
chưa kiểm tra và vẫn thể làm được mà Đâu
phải nhất thiết nó về kiểu phải hack
khủng nó thử hư đâu mà nói lên qua lỗi
bảo mật thì K lỗi ở người dùng không
được phép làm điều đấy thì Vân nữa cũng
có thể mà
à à Nói chung là đây AD des đúng không
xong rồi V.League điều hướng về
Ừ đúng rồi tôi nghĩa là tôi sẽ chia sẻ
với ông Online những cái thứ mấy không
cần biết nữa Để mấy ông mày mày ông cũng
kéo nên họ trước chúng không nên biết
trước và hôm nay tôi sẽ dạy gì Vân nữa
a Model 0ral pn hỗ trợ full stack nó bây
giờ đang dẫn mạnh về cái fulspec nó hỗ
trợ không phải mỗi pratt này tôi xem
những cái bắt của nó bây giờ nó hỗ trợ
cả kết hợp với view này hay kết hợp với
like lazaro live like We're cái gì đó
hai mấy ông tập tài liệu của nó với cả
bắt của nó đã hỗ trợ này ai Cái bữa nay
tôi xem này Cái rét của tim này nó hỗ
trợ rất là mạnh việc à Tại một cái kiểu
mua cái ra gọn ra tiện thì hiểu vân vân
Nói chung là Lara không phải hướng về
mỗi làm bác em đâu đó là full crack
cô Hà à
khi đó ngoại lumen của tao nó sẽ gọn nhẹ
hơn nếu hợp đồng avi hơn chứ còn nếu ra
ra chuẩn như thế này nó hợp làm sáng hơn
à
Ừ ok vừa rồi là toàn bộ những cái kiểu
xem thêm sửa xóa một cái gì đó đúng ạ
Nhưng mấy ông thấy thừa ra có một cái
bất tiện nữa đây đó là mấy ông thấy cái
đoạn này cái loại rất là bất tiện Tại
sao cái đoạn này rất dài về sau mấy ông
có bao nhiêu cái thì nó lặp lại bấy
nhiêu cái này thì ra thằng leo nó hỗ trợ
bụng đấy Nó toàn bộ nó sẽ gói gọn chung
một trong một cái nó sẽ freeship này
a b cho cần khai báo là
Ê bà cái tên của cái đừng dẫn nó gì mà
còn cho Alo là gì như thế này thế là đủ
sẽ xóa toàn bộ lại đi này
xe tải
mô tả lại cha mày
áo vest nó defined
Ê con đấy restore nhỉ Hình như cái này
không biết đâu là tên hơi say nhớ
restore Vậy à
em ở đâu Hình như là kìa À hình như cái
thêm ít Ok mấy cái Tôi tưởng nó không ép
cơ thể dạy nhé à Ok dạo này tớ gọi cái
mép
đấy thì mấy ông thấy à nó sẽ Kiểu cái
cái toàn bộ li ruột nó sẽ gồm những cái
gì thì mới ông cha gì xuống cho mày nhé
khu resort APN
anh không Không phải cái này đâu suốt
à à
Em
không nhớ anh nhiều cách viết
đây tôi gì Sao cắn cho lô hàng như này
thì nó sẽ gồm những cái gì nó sẽ có gồm
đầy đủ tất cả những cái này
nó sẽ cặp gen này to này sâu này sau để
hiển thị ra một hàng cụ thể này Giáo sư
trong trường hợp này mày ông không muốn
dùng nó sau này vì chẳng có thằng trâu
này ông Xóa đi một tiếp theo là ông thể
loại bỏ nó đi phải access loại trừ có đi
lại có rất nhiều cách để mà ông Loại hẳn
một cái áo đấy à
anh ở đây méo Hãy đọc kỹ hơn cách nó
viết mà photphat là hai cho chị đó nó kỹ
hơn nữa nhá giúp ở đây ạ loại trừ có đi
làm hả chị lấy một vài cái này nó cũng
được Rất tiện này Hãy giả sử tôi sẽ sửa
đây Tôi sẽ loại trừ với sâu đi chẳng ạ
Vì
sao đi ngay à
Em hãy để tránh trường hợp việc cái trâu
đấy ám chỉ ở kiểu giả sử ở mấy ông gõ
như thế này thì nó sẽ nhảy Xem cái thằng
mà có thằng có thẻ ID kiểu ngay
ở Zalo tôi xóa rồi anh ơi nó báo lỗi nha
Còn nếu mà không có nó sẽ chạy được thôi
thử nhé á
xe tải nó sẽ nó sẽ ở kiểu nó sẽ nhảy vào
cái main HP mày sao mày không theo ai
à à anh
Bởi vì không có nên mặc định là nó sẽ bị
ghi đè ở những cái thằng ở dưới này sẽ
báo lỗi
Ok chưa
ở đây ở cách viết dần dần Tôi đang dậy
mày ông cách viết dần dần dần để ngắn
gọn hơn nữa để cách các quy tắc của
thằng lauriel nó kẹo làm tối ưu cho việc
cả caud xem thêm sửa xóa còn đứng như là
mấy ông thực tế làm về sau không phải là
mỗi xem trên trời xóa đồ ăn hay tôi sẽ
hướng dẫn cho mấy ông rất nhiều cái nữa
là kiểu mấy ông cần phải làm rất nhiều
cái thì cái
Ừ cái á á
Ừ cái đấy tôi sẽ hướng dẫn mày ông cụ
thể chi tiết sau
thảm len trong vòng bao lâu quá à
em mới mở tội khẳng định là thôi vẫn
chưa hẳn là thợ lắm như toàn bộ cái các
bạn ấy ra tội nắm rõ rồi con à
Ừ để mà họ claire hồi đấy để làm toàn bộ
tính năng thêm sữa xóa này tội Mất tầm
1,2 tháng gì đó với tôi nắm rõ MBC rồi
nên tôi nghĩ là tôi dậy trong mấy ông
kiểu như này à
ở mấy cái mẹo vừa rồi Thôi đọc hihi Tôi
nhớ là hình ở trên tài liệu nó không có
mà tôi xem với claire tiếp cận cảnh
những cái miệng cái trang khác hơn
Ừ
đúng rồi nhìn cái gì ruộng này trong
phải nhắn thế rồi nhưng mà về sau là
kiểu mình sẽ không rất nhiều cá Mình
không dùng của nó mình cứ phải sét liên
tục như thường ở phía sau mình hướng
dùng theo cái cách này hơn tôi tôi cứ
giữ cả hai này trong ngày hôm quen nhé à
có người yêu rồi đây có vẻ có đang rất
nhiều Bạn đang học L'Oreal lâu rồi nên
mới kiểu bình luận cậu kia nhưng mà chắc
là tôi cũng sẽ chịu được thêm cho các
bạn một vài mẹo đó nhà anh thôi còn thêm
cái ở đây tôi quên chưa Nói mấy ông đó
là ờ đây là cách viết theo kiểu của đối
tượng nhé Còn cách viết theo kiểu là
kiểu của Eric quân a của careerbuilder
để sẽ ở ngay rồi thì à
khi tiêm chóp s đây này
ô
tô thêm một cái lý do như thế này để
thay vì tôi viết theo kiểu dạng như này
tôi thấy viết ngắn hơn nữa
khi tôi bị lưỡi sẽ biết làm cái cửa ngay
là mình sẽ có khái niệm mà crash như này
và đương nhiên là mình cũng sẽ chuyên đi
quét kiểu giống hết ngay thôi led này
bản chất là nó sẽ giống nó sẽ khởi tạo
cái hàng đối tượng này vào nó sẽ kiểu
cũng lắp đầy vào như thế này và nó sẽ
lưu lại
à à điều hướng về
à à
An đăng ký kết pi kết thúc rồi
Nếu
mà cái thằng này nó Cái thằng này à
ô tô copy rồi nha
mình mấy ông cũng có thể viết theo kiểu
dạng đấy theo update kiểu ngay nhưng mà
chắc chắn đây không phải lưu nữa mà lưu
là khởi tạo mà đúng không Mình sẽ viết
hay chọn ngay file này tìm cái thằng
Boss này sau đó lại lấp đầy dữ liệu và
xếp lại như này bây giờ cách viết hay
các loại Oppa mà mày tôi từng dạy mấy
ông ấy còn đây là cách viết theo kiểu
quay video để ngăn bàn theo kiểu nó sẽ
tự tạo ra câu SQL cho cái việc đấy con
cu con Na à Cậu Oppa cho cậu hướng đối
tượng này mày không thấy hơi thể hướng
đối tượng không ạ khởi tạo đối tượng này
xong rồi Kiểu lưu lại đối tượng ngay dẫn
chạy được nhé Cả hai nó vẫn chạy được
nghe đấy tôi sẽ ghi lại cho mấy ông kéo
ngay trong bêtông quen dần nhớ lại về
cái không đối tượng nếu ông chơi cách
nạp được không ạ Và rất nhiều lúc là mấy
ông phải cho cách này chứ không phải
loại cơ kiểu chơi thôi cậu cách tắt kiểu
ngay kéo miếng bị nhiều nhiều ông hoặc
chính tôi ở nước rất ghét kiểu đối tượng
kiểu ngay tự nhiên mất công khai báo đối
tượng ngay rồi sửa sửa các thử thứ tư
à À quên người quên hài cost rồi thì có
thể không cần file nữa Chỉ cần nghe
phiêu là được đội đây là cost như này là
sao mày à Ừ nó cũng được tại béo thể một
trời một trong hai cách kiểm nha à
a web Browser là dpp bùa không Mình nhớ
không lầm là cái á Đúng rồi quay video
chuẩn lúc đầu để BT bố nhưng mà cái là
quần là quần gì nhưng nó hỗ trợ cho cả
cái gọi cho cậu cậu kiu cậu ngay mà sẽ
xem lại nhé Sếp hài nó là gì nhé sẽ rất
là mua đồ à
3 cách để xem cái này dễ thôi mình sẽ
xem theo cậu à
Anh quay nha à
thế này à Nó hỏi quay bưu đô nó là điều
đô của alawar ok
khi
mở đây đây đây cái ha mà là quay nó cũng
là Build Ơ nó là biểu đồ nhà là khỏe
được quần chứ không phải của quay
brother ok
chú ý mình ở thế nghĩa là bản chất cái
bưu đơn nó vẫn là tạo Nó là tạo ra câu
SQL Đồ ngoại cái này nó sẽ không phải là
đối tượng giống như thằng ngày tại sao
tôi phải nhấn mạnh đi Nhấn mạnh lại việc
đối tượng hay không Bởi vì sau về sau
tôi sẽ dậy cho mấy ông cái khái niệm này
với ông vì sao thể tham khảo ở chỗ nào
kể cái bị đơ đúng không ạ Và
đ.l quần nó biến đối tượng là sẽ chậm
hơn mà quay Winner chắc chắn thôi Để
thằng cu em bưu đơn thuần thôi Đấy là sự
Các bạn cứ đây à
em thấy á
ở đây mình đang dạy ở béo mẹ lâu quần
đúng không đây về sau cái quần này nó
lại ngon hơn một cái quay điểm giống như
bạn kia bảo nó cái này đúng nó nhanh hơn
nhưng thấy quần này nó có mục đích khác
là nó sẽ bắt được sự kiện bắt được Y Vân
những cái sự kiện khi khi mà mình là một
cái gì đó thêm mới sửa sửa cái gì đó thì
cái cái sự kiện sẽ bắt được chứ không
Thằng Cu Al đơn này là câu at work thật
nó không bắt được mấy cái điều đấy nhà
sử gia sửa khi mộng Delete ông chạy theo
cậu như này khởi tạo đối tượng sẽ ôm
Delete Hay là ông khởi tạo đối tượng rồi
ông update như này chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ
có bán là một cái sự kiện và mấy ông
thầy bắt đấy theo cái sự kiện để ứng xử
lý gì đó Tiếp theo hoặc là ông thể xử lý
gì đó trước khi xóa cũng được có rất
nhiều sự kiện thì mới ông thể tham khảo
về sau mấy ông đọc thì ông sẽ ở đây sẽ
là à ờ ờ
hai tay ngay trong này có này quần này
âm nhạc cho tôi xem tôi tôi nhớ là có
đoạn nào để
hồ sơ vậy
ở đây
A6 sẽ có những sự kiện này
a-class này khi mà tạo xong này khi mà
cập nhật xong này này còn nhớ còn sự
kiện nữa Kệ offs này là chị tương đối
này nữa đứa còn sự kiện đó mày nghỉ à
à à
300 lại sự kiện này họp sớ Đúng rồi học
sờ ư
ừ ừ
ở đây đây đây những nghi vấn của thằng
thằng này được này Nó rất nhiều ạ
các tổ hợp phím nào để mà chạy thì trong
ipa này sẽ là ẩn mình sẽ ấn An xong rồi
gọi đến thôi Có nhiều cái không gọi được
có như cái gọi được
anh ăn thôi chứ nhóm nhạc control Ăn
chuối
ăn control này nó sẽ bấm được vào à
Ở đây có những sự kiện này có thể này
khi mà lấy thông tin ra này khi đang tạo
này nghĩa là trước khi tạo trước khi xếp
đưa trong bê này chế tạo xong ngồi làm
gì đấy Cái này kể tạo xong rồi làm gì
rất phù hợp với việc Khách hàng vừa bị
đăng ký thật tài khoản đấy thì béo gửi
mail thông báo thành công này Ờ
khi mà đăng lưu lại là khi đã mặc định
lưu lại này nó sẽ là hình như là nó Cả
in ra và cả update thì phải đấy nhiều
cái lắm Để có rất nhiều cái sự kiện có
thể xảy ra của khi mà đối tượng nó được
làm cái gì đó như là tôi đang hướng mấy
ông dậy dậy trong bé ông nào làm hai Còn
đối tượng chứ có không dạy cho mấy ông
hướng hoàn toàn theo kéo là quay bưu đô
hay Đạt yêu còn bị đơ thuần như này
và đương nhiên cái này có nhược điểm là
như bạn kia cũng vừa nói xong đó là cái
quay bơ này nó sẽ nhanh hơn còn cái cái
này bởi vì nó qua quá nhiều bước qua
việc khởi tạo đối tượng săn mồi bắt sự
kiện và Vân cho rồi về giống chưa khai
báo Sự kiện với cả nhau Nó vẫn sẽ chạy
qua những cái đấy kiểm tra xem có sự
kiện hay không nên nên là
nên là cái này nó sẽ kiểu nó sẽ chậm hơn
so với những cái này nhưng mà về sau về
sau mấy ông làm hãy đừng như tôi hồi đầu
tôi làm mà leo leo tôi cũng chưa bị lười
đọc thì mình cái tài liệu về cái sự kiện
này Vân Vân tôi không làm hoàn toàn theo
hướng đối tượng tôi không làm kiểu đấy
mà tôi sẽ chị mà tôi dùng hết là câu SQL
thận trên Excel thuần Nội dùng cái này
ra là vì sao mà
phát triển thêm cái gì đó thì
chị Mimi ông sẽ thấy nhập điểm mình mình
một bát một cái sự kiện gì đó là sử Xóa
Hay Thay đổi cái gì đó cần phải chạy cái
gì đó thì mới ông sẽ phải phải sửa cốt
khá nhiều thay vì thằng lao nó hỗ trợ
sẵn rồi nếu không hiểu không Đây là phải
có những cái chỗ nào mà Mấy ông cần phải
chỗ đấy phải xử lý nhanh và cập nhật
nhiều thằng cùng một lúc nhờ thằng cùng
lúc đấy còn việc cập nhật dân hành cùng
một lúc như thế này thì tôi nghĩa chơi
theo kiểu là đối tượng và ngon nhất còn
nếu mà cập nhật nhờ thằng cùng một lúc
thì bé ông có thể cân nhắc việc là sử
dụng quay Thuận nói chung à không phải
ngẫu nhiên thằng leo nó có cái vụ cho
quay thật như thế này cho biết ông Nếu
mà cái này rất là nó có giữ lại vì lý do
của nó như là nó tạo ra cái này cũng vì
do của nó
Ừ thì à
Ừ đấy câu hỏi lại bài tập về nhà tiếp đi
cho mấy ông đó là ờ
Ừ cái hàm Plus này hàm kết này theo mấy
ông nó là nó là kiểu à
Anh quay builder hay là hay là kiểu
Halloween theo cả là nó có khởi tạo đối
tượng này không
A và update này thì nó có khởi tạo đối
tượng hay không tương tự thằng này lại
cho bé ông Nếu thử nghiên cứu nha class
này và bết
khi sex
à à
Ờ ờ bữa hôm nay cho phận chưa làm được
hai bạn bữa mày Tôi chỉ làm tổng hợp cho
một bảng tốn thời gian rồi nhớ mà buổi
hôm sau rồi tôi tôi sẽ copy đúng cái sự
đúng cái này để tôi làm cho mấy ông mấy
ông sẽ thấy da kiểu nó nhanh mà tiện như
thế nào để chọn cho tôi tạm à
vi phạm phải xóa bớt ạ Để tôi độ đẩy cốc
lên mà ông sẽ thấy khá sợ vì không ai
cập nhật khá nhiều cốt luôn
à Tôi nhớ tôi còn xóa Zippo ấy rồi đấy
ừ ừ
Ừ đợi tí nhé có xe
Vì sao cái này thôi tôi tôi xóa depot
rồi thì tạo lại
ở mỗi ông kia thấy bánh cuốn rồi bởi vì
rõ ràng mà
tôi đang dạy khá nhiều cái mới và những
cái ông đã từng học cái này rồi nếu
không sẽ thấy rất tiện có những ông mà
chưa học cái này sẽ bị choáng nhờ tôi
đang hướng là để trong mấy ông đi làm
nên mới không phải quen nên việc làm mấy
hơi bị choáng kiến thức một tí nhưng còn
hơn nữa đi làm đấy ông bị thoái nước
đúng ạ mày ông chậm Một chồng hai
ờ vợ tao xóa bớt mấy cái mà không không
dùng đĩa Oishi sẽ thư cứ dậy với ông cái
đấy sao tôi ế
ở đường à
Ừ có gì em nhỉ Lại cho tương đối thế
thôi
ex1 giờ này chú ý
cách xóa toàn bộ ở trong thư mục ID ở
đây này à
Ừ vậy thì tôi sửa lại cái gif này
tôi sẽ xóa toàn bộ những cả bỏ quan cái
toàn bộ trong cái điều này là để cho hỗ
trợ IDM không cần đâu
à à
Ừ nếu không lên cài kết sắp của tôi để
xem thuốc nhé
ô ô zo thử máy tích hợp you hơn tình yêu
đôi có đấy Kiểu gì chẳng có một ông cầm
cái đấy nhưng mà tốt nghĩa tội gì mà Ông
làm theo view à
à à
ở khách sạn ở hôm nay cũng với những bạn
mới nó sẽ bị quá dài tôi không thể khẳng
định nó đơn giản được hôm nay tôi cũng
chỉ dám dậy mua bạn thôi hả Tí về sửa
lại tới đây nữa
nhưng mà tôi tin là cốt cốt nó rất là
ngắn thì trông bé uống thể xem tham khảo
không ạ Có giá ngắn tôi đang cố viết dài
ra trong dài thôi thì ra mấy ông thấy
toàn 12 dặm thôi ông ạ và và mấy ông
hiểu được tác dụng nó rồi trong qua nó
rất là mới mình không nhớ thì mới ông
chỉ làm để không làm nhiều mà không nhớ
thôi review rõ cả cái nắp trứng sao tôi
đang làm quen với nắp chẳng phải làm
quen view Thì thế mới đang làm quen thôi
tối chả chưa cho phải ba bốn tháng nữa
tôi sẽ thử Quay lại thử thử thông báo cụ
thể Tôi sẽ dạy cho béo nát hãy lưu hay
gì đó sau ở trong là sau cái khóa này đã
ờ ờ
anh em chưa biết cái gì mà chưa biết cái
gì bây giờ nói xong mà Nếu mấy ông mà
học mấy bữa trước về mới xe ok rồi thì
công nhận là bây giờ nó đang dễ hơn so
với hồi học mới ko p thuần cái này ở
trong khẳng định được đóng ạ nếu không
sẽ thấy mọi thứ nó nhanh và tiện hơn và
cũng cốt đỡ phức tạp hơn vì hỏng
Facebook nó hỗ trợ cho mình hết rồi ông
ạ
Nên là kiểu các bạn sẽ thấy là nó tiện
hơn và nó giải quyết được Cái quan trọng
là nó giải quyết được cái bài toán đó là
đó là kiểu về sau mình muốn nâng cấp
mình muốn thêm thay đổi cơ sở dữ liệu
hay gì đó thì thì level hỗ trợ được là
mình sẽ đỡ phải sửa cốt nhiều mình mình
tối ưu được cốt các tưởng mình sửa mình
sửa một chỗ tất cả chỗ khác vẫn phải
chạy được cái thì mục tiêu của các bên
word mục tiêu của mô hình brush chuẩn nó
phải như thế nào ạ vì thế nếu không sẽ
phải luôn suy nghĩ cái cái suy nghĩ để
trong đầu chán đi nếu mà ông còn theo
ngoài này đó là mình mình cốt sao cho về
sau đỡ phải sửa nhiều nhất có thể đỡ ảnh
hưởng những chỗ khác nóng lạnh tại chỗ
nào tối ưu được chỗ nào kéo về sau dãy
sửa thì mình mình làm gì đó cảm như thế
Ừ Ok nói chung và tôi cũng rất khuyến
khích người ông đặt thêm những câu hỏi
nữa để mà nếu mà tôi tôi nhớ ra tôi sẽ
giải đáp về cho mẹ ông tiện
Ừ ừ thì thế nên là tôi hồn mà tôi dậy
mới giày ô B mấy ông thì mấy ông thấy à
Nó cũng rất giống cái mà hôm nay tôi
đang đi cập đấy tôi đã dạy cho bé mình
những cái Hà nó là thứ rồi ông những cái
Hàn mặc khởi tạo đối tượng nó giống hệt
như thế này rồi ông ạ Để ông làm quen
rồi
ở Tây Tạng bộ không ai Chắc là chỉ kết
thúc tại đây không nhỉ các bạn có sao
băng gì chị
đề thi cẩu bình luận hoặc nhắn tin sau
nha
Ừ thôi cho bé ông nhé